republicano Kevin mccarthy quien había
sido nominado por su partido en una
votación interna para hacer el próximo
presidente de la cámara de
representantes no logró los 218 votos
necesarios para ser confirmado En el
cargo Después de tres votaciones de la
plenaria de la cámara baja que se
hicieron desde el medio día de ayer algo
que no pasaba desde 1923 20 congresistas
del ala más conservadora de los
republicanos votaron a favor del
representante a la cámara Jim Jordan
congresista que curiosamente terminó
votando para confirmar a mccarthy Y es
que las concesiones que hizo mccarthy a
estos congresistas no fueron suficientes
y la parálisis evidencia una división
entre el partido republicano que se
enfrenta para endurecer las políticas
migratorias reducir el tamaño del
gobierno y de sus programas sociales y
limitar la lucha contra el cambio
climático entre otras medidas la disputa
interna le resta también poder frente a
los demócratas que apoyaron por
unanimidad
nuevo líder de La minoría demócrata en
la cámara baja y primera afroamericano
en ocupar el cargo el ciclo de
votaciones continuará hoy al mediodía de
Washington hasta que Kevin mccarthy u
otro candidato logre la mayoría de 218